what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch the
official trailer for the bad batch
season dose forgive me for being late to
this guys it's been a really busy week
we're gonna be going out of town from
the 12th to the 20th so been uh prepping
a lot of movie reactions mainly in
advance to be going up on the channel
while uh we are away yeah the bad batch
I wish I had time to re-watch clone wars
in season one of the bad batch but uh
either way I'm looking forward to this
show very intrigued to see what
direction it goes after a really epic
finale if you didn't catch our reaction
to that that's up here on the channel
but yes use the force to leave a like I
did hear Commander Cody is going to be
back in this which is exciting haven't
seen him since Clone Wars or
technically revenge of this yeah Clone
Wars because that was like the last
opinion okay you know I'm trying to get
it all right guys let's do this
[Music]
holy crap that is striking
go go go go go go
we went over the plan five times
did not we need to pick up hang on
[Music]
such Pirates of the Caribbean vibes
so this is the top team
roll clones on the run from the empire
hello
see
the Empire's growing stronger we should
be doing more
I'm with you Echo be free then pull off
this Heist and you can have a future
rumors are more and more clones have
been questioning the order then they are
traitors like the Jedi
interesting oh look for them interacting
everything because of me we made the
right choice Omega but there are others
out there who need our help
what sort of treachery is this
oh it's kanji
[Music]
[Applause]
looks the enemy the Empire seeks to
establish peace and Order throughout the
Galaxy peace
[Music]
it's never an option
we're soldiers we do what needs to be
done I either definitely getting
involved with the Rebellion different we
make our own choices
what do you need Rex any chance I could
use you for a mission
Terrace the bad badge new season
streaming January 4th only on Disney
plus eight there's a lot in that trailer
holy [ __ ] there's so much going on all
right let's talk about I'll be skimming
this trailer as we are talking that
animation like this looks so much bigger
in scale feels so much more high stakes
and I feel like a common complaint of
the of the first season while a lot of
people really loved it and I quite
enjoyed it myself was that some episodes
felt like they were like just a little
too much Filler episodes I know not
everyone shares that criticism I would
be like yeah you could have excise a few
of those episodes even though I pretty
much enjoyed the whole package there's a
few that they could have excised this
looks like I mean at least the
impression I'm getting they're probably
just pulling just the right footage that
this might be a little bit more focused
and more action drama heavy which I
would hope for the series a big takeaway
from this was having that scene with
Cody and crosshairs interacting with
each other which I thought was uh very
it's going to be an interesting
different uh perspectives to be
exploring because crosshairs he had the
chip removed and from the order 66 chip
was removed but he still decided to stay
with the Empire versus Cody who I don't
think has had the chip removed but they
were even talking about you know uh
clones questioning the events of Order
66 and even in that conversation just
that little bit of exchange he looked in
conflict over it so it has me curious to
see what Direct they take with Cody
because clearly he's still working for
the Empire I don't know what direction
they'll go with that if there will be
some type of redemption Arc they put him
on the bad batch they know how to get
rid of of those chips can they over can
can Cody overcome it will will he
sacrifice himself in the end I don't I
don't know what the the future for Cody
is but it seems like it's going to be an
integral part of this series I mean just
the idea of him and crosshairs
interacting with each other and perhaps
seeing Cody have some of that internal
struggle where you know he's got this
chip in his brain which is you know
literally doing a number on his brain
reworking the way he thinks and feels
but being in conflict with that will
have like battling though there's
there's actually something wrong with
this but he doesn't know how to really
Choose Or what to overcome so I I think
that's a neat step and of course we got
gunji back here with his lightsaber
that's good kanji lives we got Rex as I
see here and saying going on another
mission you can't do this without wrecks
you always Gotta Have Rex in here at
this point would he be with Ahsoka Tano
would we get an Ahsoka Rex crossover
episode in here you gotta love it
whenever he can get more Ahsoka right
and tales of the Jedi uh by the way if
you haven't seen a reaction to that that
show was also awesome so in a weird way
like watching tales of the Jedi that
kind of reinvigorated my uh my
excitement to see the bad batch come
back oh yes uh it looks like we're
probably gonna be getting a lot more at
least the trailer seemed to emphasize
Echo quite that much more you know I I
think Echo is a very compelling
character is one that's just very tragic
and I think it'd be awesome to to get
more Echo because I I didn't really feel
like we got as much development of him
as a character in season one which makes
sense to me because it's the bad batch
we're introducing the these I mean like
they were introduced in Clone Wars but
this is their show so we got to keep the
focus mainly on them and you're
introducing Omega to get Echo to have
like more of this drive like it's like
he seems like he'd be the real thrust to
encouraging the group to be really
actively getting involved with fighting
against the empire and fighting with the
Rebellion like you see bail Organa in
here and that's a clear indicator that
perhaps this will be the season where
they really do team up with the
rebellion and kind of Go full force or
maybe it ends that way or they're going
to be setting up season three I'm really
not sure that we'll probably see more
clones that we've come to know and love
from previous Star Wars seasons as well
don't know if crosshairs will ultimately
turn into a good guy I actually like the
idea of just kind of keeping him as a
villain they did so much of a back and
forth game with him in the first season
but I think it'd be neat if they just
kind of kept him that way I also kind of
get the impression that we'll get more
Tech this time around Tech might
actually be my one of my favorite of the
bad bad I might lean towards Tech I'm
not sure I don't know either way this
looks really cool this looks big this
looks exciting and it's coming out
before the Gameplay trailer for Jedi
Fallen order comes out so perhaps maybe
they'll be connected in some way I don't
know either way leave a like subscribe
and uh hey let's end this with a
Anissa Oliva Anissa I wanted to
personally thank you for just the
amazing awesome gift that you got Olivia
and I as we are getting married it is uh
it is so sweet of you to like Olivia was
so excited he was so excited we got it
so oh I even though I know John's your
your number one you're number one here I
wanted to be here to tell you thank you
for being such a treasure in my life and
in our lives and for being so loyal to
us as a friend as a fellow reject
and for supporting us through thick and
thin throughout the years and also to
never see me to judge us I've been
pretty honest with you we've had some
private conversations and I love how
accepting you are and always encouraging
of a human being you're just a great
soul and I love you I need you to know
that I really love you you're amazing
merry Christmas and I hope you have a
more Kick-Ass 2023.
[Music]